y lo que vemos aquí se conoce como
pirámide trófica y en el contexto de la
biología la palabra trófica se refiere a
las relaciones alimentarias así que esto
nos dice quién se come a quien quien
transforma energía y quién es capaz de
aprovechar esa energía vamos a ver en la
base de la pirámide trófica tenemos a
los productores primarios productores
primarios que también se conocen como
autótrofos porque tienen la capacidad de
tomar la energía del sol energía del sol
tienen la capacidad de tomar la energía
del sol y los nutrientes que se
encuentren disponibles para almacenar
esa energía en forma de biomasa biomasa
es una palabra elegante para llamar a la
sustancia del organismo que
esencialmente almacena energía cuando
alguien les dice que tal comida tiene un
cierto número de calorías es porque
contiene esa energía almacenada las
calorías son una unidad de energía
supongamos que tomamos un metro cuadrado
del suelo si tuvieras que comparar con
respecto a un metro cuadrado supongamos
que los productores primarios de este
ambiente tienen la capacidad de
almacenar 20 mil kilocalorías por metro
cuadrado 20 mil kilocalorías por metro
cuadrado al año y lo interesante de una
pirámide trófica es que nos ayuda a
describir qué bueno esa energía
almacenada es biomasa pero después qué
sucede
y después podemos subir al siguiente
nivel que es en donde se encuentran los
consumidores primarios vamos a
describirlo en el nivel 1 se encuentran
los consumidores primarios y estos son
los organismos que se comen a los
productores primarios pero no toda esta
energía está almacenada como biomasa en
estos organismos de hecho hay mucha
pérdida porque en promedio cuando
analizan los ecosistemas se dice que
sólo aproximadamente el 10% de la
energía se transmite de un nivel a otro
de la pirámide trófica así que en este
nivel por cada metro cuadrado en lugar
de que se almacenen 20.000 kilocalorías
de biomasa por año solamente se almacena
el 10 por ciento de eso así que
solamente se almacenan 2000 kilocalorías
por metro cuadrado
ahora pasemos al siguiente nivel en
donde tenemos a los consumidores
secundarios que son aquellos que se
alimentan de los consumidores primarios
los del primer nivel y como dijimos solo
se almacena el 10% de energía y el otro
90% se va a otra parte así que en este
caso sólo se transfieren aproximadamente
200 kilocalorías por metro cuadrado al
año y así sucesivamente ahora vamos con
el siguiente nivel
estos son los consumidores del tercer
nivel o también conocidos como
consumidores terciarios y en este caso
solamente almacenan 20 kilocalorías por
metro cuadrado al año pero esto no
significa que cada metro cuadrado tenga
exactamente 20 kilocalorías de biomasa
de por ejemplo serpiente esto significa
que cuando analizamos la biomasa de las
serpientes y la aproximamos al área de
superficie
ecosistema en promedio se almacenan 20
kilocalorías por metro cuadrado al año
finalmente en la cima de la pirámide se
encuentra el nivel 4 del consumidor y
como está en la cima de la pirámide
también se conoce como súper depredador
pero recuerden que en cada nivel
solamente se puede transferir el 10% de
la biomasa así que a este nivel sólo se
le transfieren 2 kilocalorías 2
kilocalorías por metro cuadrado al año
lo más genial de todo esto es que nos
ayuda a entender mejor todo lo que puede
sustentar el ecosistema ya que puede
sustentar una gran cantidad de biomasa
de los productores primarios pero muy
poca biomasa de los súper depredadores y
por eso si vamos al bosque encontraremos
muy pocos súper depredadores porque si
pensamos en la biomasa de los súper
depredadores como kilocalorías y las
distribuimos en la región donde tienen
que encontrar comida será mucho menor
que la
promedio por metro cuadrado de por
ejemplo de pasto y árboles ahora una
pregunta muy interesante es hacia dónde
se va toda esa energía bueno en la
mayoría de los casos estos organismos se
mueven hacen cosas tienen procesos
ocurriendo en sus cuerpos y todo eso
genera calor incluso las plantas generan
calor se libera energía en forma de
calor a partir de todos estos seres
además cuando estos seres mueren son
descompuestos por otros organismos así
que toda esta biomasa morirá o será
comida por alguien más pero aún cuando
es comida no se transfiere toda la
energía ya que muchas de ellas se queda
en la materia que no es digerida es
decir el excremento o popó así que la
biomasa muerta o popó que todavía
contiene energía es alimento para otros
organismos conocidos como
descomponedores
descomponedores que lo que hacen es
descomponer y convertir la materia en
nutrientes que podrán ser aprovechados
por los productores primarios al mismo
tiempo que usan la energía del sol y se
repite el ciclo
qué pasaría si existiera algún cambio en
el ecosistema qué pasaría si por ejemplo
hiciera erupción un volcán que se
encuentra cerca lo dibujaré si el volcán
hiciera erupción y la ceniza tapar el
cielo de gris durante todo el año qué
pasaría bueno
la cantidad de energía solar que choca
contra la superficie de esta área
disminuiría en grandes cantidades y si
esa energía escasea entonces los
productores primarios no podrían
almacenar 20 mil kilocalorías por metro
cuadrado al año sino que esa energía
bajaría a 2.000 kilocalorías por metro
cuadrado al año y por lo tanto todo lo
demás desciende aquí en lugar de 20 mil
bajaría a 2000 aquí en lugar de 2000
bajaría a 200 en lugar de 200 bajaría a
20 en lugar de 20 bajaría a 2 y en lugar
de dos
bajaría a 0.2
así que algo como la pérdida de energía
luminosa aún cuando este súper
depredador no realiza la fotosíntesis
directamente muy pocos de ellos podrían
sobrevivir en el ecosistema si existe
una menor energía almacenada como
biomasa en la producción del primer
nivel porque habría menos energía del
sol para ser almacenada como biomasa y
bueno también podrían suceder otras
cosas en el ecosistema supongamos que se
introducen algunos pesticidas en el
ecosistema y algunos organismos del
nivel 1 se empiezan a morir entonces
ahora habría menor cantidad de biomasa
para transferir del productor primario
al nivel de los consumidores primarios
lo que nuevamente afectaría a los
niveles superiores de la pirámide
trófica
y es muy interesante pensar en esto
porque nos damos cuenta de que los
ecosistemas están entrelazados de una
forma muy compleja y el impacto en una
de estas áreas puede tener consecuencias
de gran alcance a través de todo el
ecosistema pero también es muy
interesante pensar en los ecosistemas
como transferencias de energía la
energía llega del sol y viaja a través
del ecosistema de esta pirámide un poco
de esa energía se almacena como biomasa
y se transfiere a otras formas de
biomasa pero mucha de la energía se
pierde en forma de calor mientras las
células de estos organismos realizan
diferentes procesos los organismos
corren y viven su vida haciendo lo que
sea